CREW
Here we go. 3, 2, 1, Action!
AWKWAFINA
Hold on, everybody!
SIMU LIU
Shang-Chi is, at its core, a Marvel movie.
That comes with a promise of action.
And a certain promise to the quality of
the sequences that
we're about to deliver.
KEVIN FEIGE
This film will take your breath away
on the big screen. And it is as big as
anything that we've ever brought to life
in the MCU before.
ANDY CHENG
With the bus sequence,
everything had to be perfect.
DESTIN DANIEL CRETTON
That was something I've never done before.
Taking a bus down San Francisco
hills and crashing into real cars.
SIMU LIU
We are using literally every single inch
of that bus and figuring out
what we can do with it.
KATY
We make a good team!
SIMU LIU
Some days I work out harder than others.
AWKWAFINA
We're working with world class stunt teams.
Their work ethic, everything that they're
doing is like, incredible to witness.
FALA CHEN
I was training with the world champion
of tai chi and
she was absolutely amazing.
TONY LEUNG
I took two weeks to rehearse
our fight sequence. It's a symbol of
the aggressiveness and
anger of the character.
SIMU LIU
We're going to incorporate a lot of
different styles of martial arts.
Tai chi, which is very, very flowy.
Another one is Wing Chun which is a bit
more combative. And then looking at
certain regional styles to kind of fill in
this mosaic of how this character moves.
MICHELLE YEOH
This film should stand out on its own.
It's got a very magical story behind it,
mixed with a lot of action.
SIMU LIU
The world has no idea what they're up for.
WENWU
It's time for you to take your place
by my side.
SHANG-CHI
That's not going to happen.